les ségur de la santé touche à sa fin
six semaines de négociations pour
réformer l'hôpital français le
gouvernement a présenté hier soir un
nouveau projet d'accord y figurent entre
autres une hausse minimum de
rémunération de 180 euros mensuels net
pour l'ensemble du personnel hospitalier
art médecin les syndicats ont jusqu'au
13 juillet pour dire s'ils acceptent de
signer le texte
mais déjà à l'intersyndicale des
internes a fait savoir son
mécontentement dans cette mobilisation
l'a décidé la semaine dernière suite aux
premières annonces qui ont été faites
par le ministre concernant les internes
qui était bien en deçà de ce qu'on de ce
qu'on espérait et donc l'idée c'est de
avant la fin des négociations de montrer
que tout ce qu'on a fait tout ce qu'on a
fait pendant le vide il faut que ce soit
valorisée et notamment valoriser par une
augmentation de 300 euros net par mois
et ce qui nous a été proposé ses 150
euros brut par mois et que pour les
premières années l'internât ce qui peut
et historique c'est la tenue d'un
secteur de la santé et des enveloppes
allouées qui qui font que continuer à
tomber et qui essaye d'être plus
essentielle sensationnaliste les unes
que les autres
mais là pour le moment en tout cas en ce
qui concerne les internes en médecine
de france là pour le moment nos attentes
elles sont pas qu'elles sont pas
remplies moi ce que j'en pense c'est que
pendant que ville on a entendu beaucoup
de choses et je pense que certains
d'entre nous un certain espoir qu'on
allait enfin être écoutés que là
aujourd'hui en fait encore une fois on
nous manque de respect en nous proposant
par exemple la révélation des gardes
une réalisation qui est vraiment minime
puis à moins de 1 euros brut de l'heure
en plus pour moi c'est un manque de
respect